[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
die augen gucken wir sagen verdammt noch
mal warum warum diese bestialische art
und weise 37 messer stellt ihr selbst
unter der fußsohle
wie krank ist das und das wort
gerechtigkeit wo ist die für uns wir
kriegen bis zum lebensende keine wählen
[Musik]
die zornigen worte stammen von maria
rimbach sie ist die mutter von heike
rimbach die gerade 19 jahre alt ist als
ihr leben endet heike ist bis dahin eine
fröhliche junge frau mit langen blonden
locken grübchen und frechem grinsen sehr
träume hoffnungen und den wunsch nach
einem glücklichen leben sie streichelt
ihre geliebte katze am letzten
gemeinsamen abend vor ihrem tod am 28
august
1995 nur eine erinnerung auf
verblichenen fotopapier
26 jahre nach einer tat die bis heute
ungesühnt ist denn heike wurde
erschlagen erstochen gewürgt und
schließlich stranguliert im haus ihrer
eltern
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen ausgabe von tatort
deutschland das verbrechen an heike
rimbach und ihre familie ist ein cold
case ein mord der bis heute ungeklärt
ist
[Musik]
der familie endlich die gewissheit gibt
warum
bild chefreporter thilo scholtyseck
sucht für tatort deutschland nach bald
drei jahrzehnten erneut eine antwort auf
die frage wer ist der mörder von heike
dafür trifft er die mutter von heike
rimbach und einen ehemaligen ermittler
er besucht den tatort und taucht ein in
den grausamen sumpf eines sinnlosen
verbrechens
[Musik]
ortstermin am ehemaligen wohnhaus der
familie rimbach das große grundstück mit
dem riesigen feld steinhaus ist
eigentlich eine alte schäferei 1 den
wenigen gehörte in lüttgenrode auf der
östlichen seite des harzes familie
rimbach zog anfang der 90er aus dem
westen in das 400 seelenlos es ist noch
nachwende goldgräberstimmung und vater
rimbach sieht gute chancen sein
bauunternehmen im osten zu etablieren
hier jedenfalls legt die damals 19
jährige heike zusammen mit ihren eltern
und ihren beiden brüdern
es ist sonntag der 27 august 1995 die
familie sitzt nach dem abendessen noch
im wohnzimmer beisammen es ist kurz nach
22 uhr 30 als heike zu bett geht am
nächsten morgen verlassen alle früh das
haus nur heike kann ausschlafen die
19-jährige macht eine ausbildung zur
metzgerei fachverkäuferin sie arbeitet
samstags montag ist er freier tag was
dann im haus geschieht gibt bis heute
rätsel auf
passiert noch
dass diese sache aufgeklärt wird gerhard
bene ist pensionierter kriminalbeamter
er und seine kollegen waren kurz davor
den fall zu lösen doch ein täter konnte
bis heute nicht verurteilt werden bene
damals schon mit vollbart kann sich noch
an die aufmacher der bild erinnern die
titelte top profiler untersucht den
mordfall heike dachboden mord katze
führte zur toten heike findet er heikes
mörder im april 1995 fängt thilo
scholtyseck als junger reporter bei der
bild-redaktion in halle an seit august
1995 berichten er und seine kollegen
über den mordfall über tatverdächtige
wendungen und gescheiterte ermittlungen
der journalist es bis heute jung und bei
der bild geblieben hat aber haarpracht
gegen designerbrille getauscht
kilo scholtyssek erreicht das grundstück
stellt seinen wagen ab- und betritt
zusammen mit ex ermittler bene das haus
und ehemaligen tatort von außen ist das
fell steinhaus in einem guten zustand
drinnen wurde bisher aber nicht viel
gemacht denn die liegenschaft steht leer
seit die familie sie nach der tat
verließ der bild-reporter steigt die
alte treppe nach oben er betritt ein
zimmer tapete und reste der einrichtung
stimmen mit der auf den fotos in der
hand des journalisten über ein dieser
muss schlucken die fotos zeigen bilder
vom verwüsteten tatort aber auch bilder
mit einer lachenden hayek in ihrem
zimmer beim rauchen die bravo und eine
kohle haben platz auf dem tisch vorm
bett dass das kinder
er hat sie gelebt und am
28 august 1995 ist sie hier in diesem
zimmer von ihrem späteren mann
überwältigt worden es ist auch
rekonstruiert wurden dass sie hier
bereits angegriffen hat sich hier
offensichtlich gewirkt gedrosselt und es
gab auch das hat die obduktion ergeben
ersten schlag auf den kopf jetzt bewegt
sich der bild-reporter gebückt aus dem
zimmer heraus amt die haltung des täters
nach der versuch die bewusstlose heike
in eine kammer auf den dachboden zu
bringen
hier entlang geschliffen über den boden
hat später schleifspuren gefunden die
hier genau durch diesen bereichen durch
diese tür und dann gab es hier damals
noch eine abtrennung mit einer kleinen
lupe und durch diese lücke hat er sich
selber durch gezwängt und dann hinter
sich hergezogen
ex ermittler gert bene studiert die
alten fotos und den grundriss des hauses
so da wegkommt
würde er mit einer erheblichen strafe
rechnen müssen
also hast ja möglicherweise in die
situationen
den entschluss aber wohin heike lebt
noch sie ist physisch stark das materie
um geht weiter eines der fotos zeigt ein
langes messer mit verziertem griff mit
diesem messerstich der täter mehrfach
auf die junge frau ein vermutlich stirbt
sie schon an diesen verletzungen aber
das reichte mörder nicht er hängt ihren
leblosen körper mit einem strick an
einen dachbalken und schlägt mit einer
art brecheisen immer wieder zu der täter
war ortskundig und er wusste auch dass
die dann später bestätigte
sich zu haus befindet das heißt er hatte
schon sehr gute kenntnisse
zeitfaktor und wirklichkeit faktor und
sowieso später stellen rechtsmediziner
fest heike ist durch massive gewalt
gestorben schläge messerstiche
strangulation jede dieser zugefügten
verletzungen hätte zum tode führen
können experten sprechen von einem
sogenannten über töten häufig eine
beziehungstat ausgelöst durch eifersucht
oder kränkung
[Musik]
wer das so präsentiert worden dass es
geklärt wird
wenn wir immer nach jahren wieder
einsteigen beziehungsweise einen neuen
nachrichten stand gibt dann berichtet
man wieder drüber und fragt sich
trotzdem ist jetzt gibt es jetzt eine
möglichkeit
deshalb trifft thilo scholtyseck heikes
mutter maria rimbach in ihrem neuen
zuhause
26 jahre nach der ermordung ihrer
tochter als erstes zeigt maria rimbach
dem journalisten eine art kleinen
schrein mit bildern von heike auch ein
plakat mit einer karikatur hängt
vergilbt in einem glas rahmen die
zeichnung spielt humorvoll darauf an
dass jedes leben wendungen bereit hält
der bild reporter und tagesmutter nehmen
platz und schon schießen tränen der
trauer und der wut in die augen der
erschöpft wirkenden frau
[Musik]
haben sie mal die bilder angeguckt wie
sie da hängt an dem fall haben sie
[Musik]
gerne stehe als täter vor und kann nach
hause fahren kann mich ins bett liegen
und schlafen
wie geht es
da kann keine psycho worden sein seit 26
jahren kämpfen maria rimbach ihr mann
und ihre beiden erwachsenen söhne nun
schon mit dem erlebten letztere haben
mittlerweile eigene familie maria
rimbach mann ist über die jahre schwer
erkrankt kann das haus nicht mehr
verlassen haben tolle familien
und darin liegt maria rimbach zeigt auf
die fenster des zimmers wo es vater als
pflegefall betreut wird
und ich habe es ihr versprochen
[Musik]
wer hat heike rimbach getötet stammt der
täter wie die ermittler vermuten aus
ihrem näheren umfeld
kannte er heike ihren mörder fest steht
am abend vor der tat für eike mit ihrem
neuen freund in dessau telefonieren
weil es aber sechs jahre nach der wende
in den kleinen ort lütgenrode noch immer
keinen telefonanschluss gibt fährt heike
zum telefonieren in einen nachbarort
doch anstelle ihres freundes erreicht
sie nur dessen mutter was wollte sie
ihrem neuen freund am abend vorher
ermordung erzählen was nur sehnsucht
oder doch eine wichtige nachricht fühlte
sie sich möglicherweise von jemandem
bedroht hatte sie angst bild
chefreporter scholtyssek und ex
ermittler gert bene tragen noch mal die
fakten der tätersuche zusammen auch
heike es eltern und ihre beiden brüder
geraten ins visier der ermittler
die eltern waren unter verdacht ja und
dann passierte einem jahrelang nichts
verbrechen
in dem sinne die ermittlungen laufen
sich im hintergrund und als dann der
erste verdächtige 2005 geschnappt wurde
ein 1 1 1 kollegen ihr kollege aus der
schlachterei von von heike rimbach
dachte man wirklich jetzt
ein metzger kollege von heike rimbach
der ihr auch nachgestellt haben soll
wird verdächtigt in bad harzburg rund 15
kilometer von lüttgenrode entfernt eine
prostituierte aus thailand erschlagen
und eine zweite schwer verletzt zu haben
der mann wird verhaftet doch für eine
anklage im fall heike rimbach reichen
die indizien nicht
thilo scholtyseck blättert durch die
fotos vom tatort es ist noch mal das
verwüstete zimmer von heike zu sehen auf
dem boden liegen unter anderem ein paar
adidas laufschuhe ein modell das
hunderttausendfach in den 90er jahren
verkauft wird diese schuhe gehören nicht
heike diese sneaker sorgen im mordfall
schließlich für eine spektakuläre
wendung
ermittler gerhard bene ist damals teil
einer neu gegründeten mordkommission 13
jahre nach der tat öffnete er erneut die
akten geht alle spuren und hinweise noch
einmal durch in der asservatenkammer
stößt er auf besagte schuhe sie gehören
heikes ex freund andreas s und wurde
1995 in zimmer von heike rimbach
sichergestellt an mehreren dieser phase
blutanhaftungen
festgestellt worden wie bei der weiteren
untersuchung
als menschen blut
und einige dieser partikel als das blut
der geschädigten festgestellt werden
konnten
forensiker des landeskriminalamtes
entdecken zudem auf den sneakern von
blut umschlossene fasern die denen des
seins mit dem heck auf dem dachboden
erhängt wird sehr ähneln hinzu kommt
kurz vor der tat trennte sich heike von
andreas s vier jahre waren sie zusammen
er kannte sich im haus der rimbachs
auskannte heikes lebensumstände der
vermeintliche durchbruch im jahr 2009
für teiges ex freund andreas s verhaftet
alles passt zusammen die gescheiterte
beziehung das über töten die indizien
maria rimbach sie den tag der
gerechtigkeit gekommen
[Musik]
ich habe wir haben noch keine anklage
anfang dezember kam dann die nachricht
es war der zweite oder dritte
haftprüfungstermin dass er seiner haft
entlassen
der haftrichter erkennt keinen
dringenden tatverdacht anklage wird
nicht erhoben auch weil ein bekannter
andreas es für die tatzeit ein alibi
gibt
dann sieht wie so kommt er raus
[Musik]
das
noch möglich war doch die beweise
reichen nicht denn nach der tat wurden
die beweismittel unsachgemäß gelagert
spuren könnten somit möglicherweise
vermischt worden seien die fasern auf
den schuhen konnten also nicht mehr ohne
jeden zweifel und unmittelbar dem
tatgeschehen und damit andreas s
zugeordnet werden nach der hoffnung also
der rückschlag der fall heike rimbach
wird endgültig zum cold case dann ist
das natürlich eine sache die immer
wieder beschäftigt weil man natürlich
mit den angehörigen gesprochen hat das
hat uns natürlich auch emotional berührt
und immer wieder bei den
ermittlungsbehörden nachgefragt wie denn
der stand ist weil man natürlich wissen
will wann wird da jemand gefasst
der reporter und der ex ermittler haben
nicht aufgegeben und vielleicht gibt es
ja noch eine chance bleibt bis zum
schluss dran es gibt noch wichtige
informationen
bis zum nächsten mal sky go
[Musik]
die polizei magdeburg will auch heute
noch wissen wem ist am vormittag des 28
august 1995 rund um die alte schäferei
in lüttgenrode etwas ungewöhnliches
aufgefallen wer kann angaben zu
auffälligen personen und
fahrzeugbewegungen rund um den tatort im
zeitraum zwischen dem 27 und 28 august
1995 machen
darüber hinaus appellieren die polizei
und die familie rimbach an täter
mitwisser oder zeugen melden sie sich
erleichtern sie ihr gewissen denn jedes
neue detail jede information kann dazu
führen dass aus dem cold case heike
rimbach nach 26 jahren ein aufgeklärter
fall wird und die familie rimbach
endlich ihren frieden findet
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone der bank
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
lutz neumann
redaktion bild thilo scholtyseck wurden
stefan netze mit
obwohl ich weiß worauf du hinaus ist auf
sex oder sagen wir man hätte besoffen
sex in der öffentlichkeit was wird da
aufgesucht das siebzehnte bundesland der
mallorca podcast mit ingo wohlfeil und
stefan netzeband wie fühlt sich der
ballermann tan in der neuen saison was
kosten aktuell flüge und hotels welche
promis sind auf der insel und welches
das im bierkönig oder mega park mit das
siebzehnte bundesland bist du immer auf
dem laufenden jeden donnerstag wo es
buhte podcast gibt
[Musik]